>> PROSVETOV.
IT'S GONNA BE O'CONNOR.
REBOUND, SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> MIKKO RANTANEN ABLE TO AVALAE
COULD SEND TO THE GAME.
BUT WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS G
COYOTES CHASING AT THEIR OWN
END.
HIGH SHOT, SHOTCKEY LEAGUE.
NOBODY WORKS SHOOTS AND
SCORES.
IT'S A SHORT-HANDED GOAL GIVEN W
THIS ONE DOWN?
IT JUST KINDAFTERWARDS.
GLOVED
THE DROP PASS FINDS MacKINNON.
CENTER ICE HE WILL COM SOME MOMF
THE POWERPLAY.
THEY HAD A NICE POWERPLAY.
THEY MOV PIECES.
CHYCHRUN FOR A WHILE.
READ IT WELL.BURS WITH A
WRIST SHOT AND HE SCORES!
[ HORN ]
>> A ONE-PLAY ABILITY.
IT.
THAT WILL COUNT AS A COMEBACK, I
SUPPOSE.
DUMPED BACK IN. HIM
THE KESSEL DARTING WITH THIS AR.
KESSEL PUMP CHECKED AWAY.
VAL GETS THE LEAD PASS AND HE'S
FLYING.
NICHUSHKIN TO THE FRONT OF THE
HAD.
>> WHEN THEY FIRST INTRODUCED
OVERTIME, THIS IS A LOW.
SCHMHM
>> KELLER, LEFT-HANDED SHOOTER.
WORKS IT IN.
NOW THE COLORADO CAN WIN BABY!
SCORE!